The endocrine system, is linked to the nervous system, by the hypothalamus,
which is one of the important structures, involved in stress, along with the
endocrine system's pituitary gland and adrenal glands. Neurons in the
hypothalamus release chemicals, which causes the pituitary gland to release
hormones. These hormones play an important role, in the response to stress.
Also important to the stress response are the adrenal glands because they
release hormones called catecholamines and glucocorticoids. Catecholamines
control the autonomic nervous system activation. Catecholamines include
dopamine, norepinephrine and epinephrine. Glucocorticoids are important because
they maintain activation of our physiological systems during emergencies.